should be back live
here
hi let's check the Discord for updates
oops one dm then I got to answer on the
side
there uh and I think we'll be reviewing
Blaster let's see
so hold
on okay so this is all this is BET
feedback contacts are a little
screwy uh update on code ball much
better last pointless
copy
nice that's
fine that usually happens
step out of line
what found a
bug tunnel through walls
this okay bet I think is just looking at
feedback investigated High compute time
Fe observations the Bott neck any idea
how to make this
quick
see do have a perf test
here so let's run
this and we will do some
up oh yeah there it is now it shows us
up okay
let's figure out what's up with this
it's and and python
maybe let's check OB
siiz D type is nump and
8 num obs
agent Site range agent Site range times
5 this is a perfectly reasonable
Xander um do you have any idea what's
weird with this thing so if I build it
in C with fast on uh it's very good
so I'm not sure where the perf drop is
coming
from let me see scon code
weird not sure just started
investigating
yeah report interval
expect is that
big don't think that should be too
21% that's
crazy your M time should not be that
slow let me make sure we didn't just
break something and Puffer that's like
suspicious yeah no it's
fine okay so where could we possibly be
dropping perf huh
wrong let me
see m.n
agents
four oh wait Max steps
slower maybe like your reset function is
super slow or
this includes compute Ops
right
yeah okay
so 2.3
million should be plenty
fast really should be plenty
fast and M
start unless I'm missing something this
looks like a perfectly good perf test
added a
call doesn't this do compute
observations
though this already does compute
observations Xander
and that's normal but if it's 2.3
million with compute observations right
because if you're doing uh if you're
profile it step that already has
computer observations in
it unless there's something wrong with
the perf test which would
like I suppose would make sense because
it's kind of
crazy for there to be that much of a
difference oh whoops yeah you're right
yeah so you're already doing that
why is uh hold
on you're only setting the action for
the first agent here to Rand percent 4
right 1.5
million but that's still plenty fast
fast do you have an llm Plugin or
something yes I have a super Maven I I
highly suggest it it's just a fast auto
complete like I don't use it for full
functions I just use it to like
autocomplete individual lines it's a
nice piping
buff well welcome back
Captain actually let me why why does
nobody tell me when I do stupid [ __ ]
like this like why does nobody tell me
when I clearly have my camera over my
terminal just be like hey Joseph you're
being an idiot fix your
term Cod EVS code
yeah this one has a neoen plugin so I
like it and it's fast and the devs are
cool
I'm trash now let's try something like
this 20
right yeah Xander it's not the thing is
compute OBS is going to be 90% of your
time in an m like this like think about
it the actual action of moving stuff
around is free like most of your uh most
your computer is going to go into
compute OBS but that's not the problem
if you're getting 1.5 million right then
you should just be fine you shouldn't
have any perf issues at
all so I'm trying to figure out where
they're coming
you're not doing anything weird in here
as far as I can see
spam why is it compiling with
o1 and O2 okay
I think O2 takes
precedence we didn't change anything
that would mess this up
snake why are they're
20 uh because cython and setup tools
basically python is stupid is
why so with multiprocessing we have 26%
but that's still
Oban it should be zero
you just have to write a python perf
test
sometimes we put these at the bottom of
files so that we can do a your python
perf test things are being
okay so according to
this you get 900,000 out of
uh out of
C do it need to be faster
like is it literally just
that that it needs to just be faster
than
this um cuz most of our M's are faster
on what if I just uh like
return okay and then I do
yeah okay so it is literally M
Speed yeah that makes sense I guess when
you add everything
up okay so let's just make it a little
faster then
it this bounce check is not
helping you'd like to amortize this
bounce check I'm trying to think how to
do it with the way you have it set up
I mean the one thing you could do would
be to
why is this so slow compared
to like what I do in snake I guess you
have all these different channels is the
oh let's reverse this to be
if not
I don't know if this is correct let's
see
that didn't help very
much for
thing I'd have to profile this
individually to
see maybe we do have to
Flip Flip the loops
and do the
math
yeah I think we got to try at
least so we're going to go
hang
on am I just not reading
oh yeah that makes absolutely no sense
at all
okay so what we're going to do is we'll
get rid of this I
[Music]
believe
unindent and then the one annoying thing
is now we have to compute this
observation
index I think it's worth it though
guess Xander is this ever
possible cell type I guess there's a
carrying option
here
um I don't understand how these OBS are
structured at the
it's carrying or not I don't understand
how that
works cuz you have or is it supposed to
be the fifth channels for carrying
added in third Loop to get rid of single
carrying
OBS okay so I don't think that was done
correctly if I did or whatever I don't
remember but um let's see
so cell
type is this entity type so this is
always one to four so we
one oh no it's
not 0 to three
I think it's something like this
Vander let me see if this actually
compiles
it's got to be these computations right
let me
there we
go that's what we want
[Music]
and then if all I do
there you go
Xander let's see if it still
learns welcome YouTube folks currently
just doing a little bit of perf
optimization on Xander's cool
environment possible my indexing math is
wrong here we will see if this thing
yeah it looks not to be training so
probably my index math is wrong
here let's figure that
out it's nice and fast though
so first of all this is this is four not
five
um cell Y is Agent to y +
D let's see so Channel offset is
range so this has got to
be yeah this is wrong so this
right uh so Xander if you're still here
what uh I did is you were looping over
each Channel you don't need to Loop over
the channels when it's just your one
hotting stuff right so you just Loop
over the uh the cell tiles you don't do
all the Redundant checks and you just
set you just compute the index of the uh
the specific cell that needs to be one
hotted I actually don't know why this is
negative one either you should just be
able to set this to
zero the way this is
is oh this is got to be this is totally
wrong
so you get your channel offset like
that out of bounds versus
inbounds oh I see why you did that okay
sure then you have to always
set you then you do have to set this to
uh to zero though
awkward well I guess what we can do is
uh
trash trash B yeah I see what you did
okay it's just slightly annoying to
compute the OBS for us all
there's just some really obnoxious
indexing math that we have to do here as
shouldn't the did you what did you
change the plus one I was recomputing
the OBS index it's not plus one it's not
contiguous in
memory pretty sure that was the permute
thing that you
had it's Channel's first first not
Channel's
this is actually the thing that's making
our lives hard here is pie torch believe
it or
not matching the way that pie torch uh
expects
data I don't know why the hell they do
it this way also it's very stupid to do
it the way that they do it but it's like
an
ingrained ingrain
choice if they use Channel's last format
which is also more efficient then we
would be able to compute data in that
it's actually incredibly obnoxious here
handling the
padding Xander I honestly think it would
be better to just add a
wall like add like a wall
type cuz having the P the observations
is just going to be
slow you
now like there's no way of doing it in
contiguous memory like
this um
and this is super
what is total num
mobs oh it already has n agents in
three
okay wait so it's plus
work oh because that's where the first
entity is duh
okay no Heap
overflow maybe now
works welcome YouTube
folks hopefully the internet holds for
today I fix those damn drivers soon
uh okay cool so that's the local
speed about
fast yes that's substantially faster
than before
still not
training how bad could I broken
offset where's grid
size grid
let's try this
[Music]
again uh it doesn't
no do I spell the indexing wrong let me
see so five
channels agent
y
obsd wait agent Site range is
five
right and then offset
it's type times Channel offset
right set this to
as soon as we get this indexing right
your uh your M will be fixed and will be
million steps per second
train as it should be welcome YouTube
folks uh the M we're currently debugging
for reference you can play it on puff. a
if you just hold shift
down uh it is this trash pickup end you
can watch these puffers
collect and uh you know collect and
return all these different
objects and we have a way to make it way
faster with some just
like changes to the way in which we're
Computing observations in the C
file but there are a couple little bugs
with
agent what did we make the
obsd didn't we make it just the 11 by 11
or whatever
now been watching back previous stream
slowly catching
up very good hey jump in the Discord
build some Ms with
us when experimenting on top of your
amps how many architectural decisions
and Hyper prams are of
importance action OB space steams could
make a big difference so the ones that
are just completely unintuitive and you
have to sweep the most sensitive are
learning rate
entropy uh gamma and J
Lambda those are purely empirical you
just have to sweep them there's some
intuition that you can develop around
these but they're usually wrong um OB
space
schemes generally there like yes there
are decisions but that can be learned
there's a method behind most of that
work um and then there are a few there
like there are several other things that
matter that we don't have a handle on
yet that is going to be the subject of
work starting in early
2025 let me figure this out
here if anybody is the indexing bug feel
free I mean this is just like
silly I mean I really don't see it here
because unless the observation didn't is
wrong hold
it's OBS dim 2 * agent Site range plus
one OB Let's uh let me just build this
and see again put a break point at like
204 okay so we have
OBS and index
here offset is
8 of
129 OBS dim is 11
yes OBS Y is
zero 9x
can be 121
can you explain the last part of the
offset yeah so what you're doing here is
uh each observation is this size uh it's
five channels and 11 by 11 so it's 5 by
11 by 11 so here you skip whatever the
agent index is Time 5 by 11 by 11 so you
skip to the current agent and then the
goal is that you skip over rows so uh
this should be this is to the first
channel so like your position in the
first channel should be your uh your y
index in the
observation times 11 and plus OBS X is
your X
offset uh into that 11 by1
window and then this bottom one here is
skipping four channels so that you do
the carrying
14 this
entity right so that doesn't make sense
does it
so we're at
204 it's right
here oh no here it is this is
good
135 this all looks
reasonable I guess I can observe uh I
can go look at these OBS and python to
see what these look like so I can't find
any issue looking at the C for
then track
is distributed around like
this this is
possible and then trash
bin I see multiple trash bins so that
should be wrong
and then agent
three I see four agents so that looks
like that could be right so the only
thing that's wrong here is I see that
there are two trash bins
somehow and then what about
four yeah four is zero so this is like
almost
reasonable the only thing that's
suspicious is the two trash bins
what is a total n mobs maybe that's
wrong
am I somehow wrong about the storage
format or something I shouldn't
correct is it plus four times Channel
offet
yes it should
why I'm trying to think what I haven't
tried yet for
this I'm staring at it's not
particularly productive
I'm like almost positive I'm just losing
track of the index
correctly is there plus one or something
no
check if the cell is within bounds
yes I I mean I have to be
setting
false if
found then
this I'm just going to see if I can
catch it double
setting on uh
format because these Loops are telling
me that I'm not
setting the bin twice per
Loop did you realize you don't actually
pre-compute pathing in
MOBA yeah so uh it's cached instead of
pre-computed
so right here if not cached and it
should cash it
otherwise so the reason for that is that
um
pre-computing if you pre-compute and
then load in 250 Megs of data on the web
it doesn't like that um and also during
training you're adding at most 3 seconds
total cuz it takes 3 seconds to
pre-compute the whole map so you're
adding three total seconds over the
whole course of training assuming that
it eventually has to do every single
possible
smarter we use the um we use the
pre-compute function for like the little
there's like this little visual toy demo
somewhere in there where you can like
you know scroll around with the mouse
and see all of the uh the pre-computed
paths in real
time do you see index logic bugs here
because I don't see any index logic bugs
here I'm almost positive I'm doing the
indexing in the right order though
let me
see oh wait hold on is
here let me just double check the
original code
so I'm almost positive that I did uh the
indexing order right
this is the correct ordering as far as I
can
there anything else that I could have
messed
up process of doing
this because those OBS really look
correct for
me why are you multiplying by the type
because I'm trying to skip that many
channels so the way it's laid out in
memory it's agents then
channels then uh rows then
columns so I'm trying to skip so I've
gone ahead by the tile offset
here and then I'm trying to skip ahead
however many channels I need to to one
hot just the specific channel that you
need
I'm going have to get dinner soon but I
really want this thing to be fixed
before
then because I fixed your speed thing
right I just have some index
work and this is now training at over a
million steps per second there's just
some little bug
X I think it's
fine and something's clearly
wrong it's five times Channel offset
BFS instead of something like
AAR it's a pre-compute anyways Captain
like it doesn't matter it's simpler and
it adds 3 seconds total that's across
all the environments on a core as well
because it's cached across environment
instances on the same
core so basically I it solved it in 3
seconds oh yeah also that the uh the way
we do it um you solve all paths with it
so uh AAR you cash less data at the same
time I
believe because each call to BFS it like
I think it caches many values at the
same time because you cash everything
along the way anyways so the only thing
that AAR lets you do is like do I guess
more calls that are less overhead
want what the hell's wrong with this
thing
um usually I don't get this hung up on
index bugs like what the heck is Amateur
hour
I don't think
so we want to jump
ahead it's a
4D tensor
right so it's like
4096 uh or like I guess four agents 5 11
by the type which is the second index
times the channels which is the number
of elements in the last two don't
you I me I could just not be seeing
something and doing something stupid
Channel
offset looks good to me like what the
I don't know why it's printing the slash
on I dumb
am I stupid why is this not printing
like normally
there we
go
go yay okay now we can actually
see
um could try just printing out each
value see if it sequential it doesn't
sequentially increases the
thing that's the annoying thing it's not
it's not laid out nicely in
memory so three are the agents 1 2 3
4 where's the trash bin did not see it
anywhere
replace that before I forget it
but one two three
4 and there's the trash
bin here's all the
trash the OBS look
fine at least the this version of the
map looks fine
right now the question
is to match
Okay
so we just need one more slash
n okay so here we
go here is our
map this one is blank this is
good and then this one
matches yeah this one
matches first channel and then second
Channel there are no
twos so this is empty and then
threes one
one
yeah so this matches exactly
good I have no idea why this doesn't
work then
right where's the two it just none of
the agents can see
it it's not in view I checked on a
larger map I made like the map OBS
larger and I saw like the one two so
that's
take another look at the uh the OBS and
the
okay that's
zero
one
22 well that doesn't make sense there's
not 22 trash
somehow I don't see how it would be
writing over
sense two trash bins the four agents is
correct
right not even the right total number of
things how do we do that
um especially when I literally just
saw I just saw printed out right from C
that we had the right
total number of things um Ops look
reasonable
like here's the big
one one two
three five six 7 8
[Music]
9 12 1 14
20 and so these OBS
are these OBS look good and then I check
that they match here as well
it should be deterministic as well
though I actually I guess I don't know
if the seating is the
same one
you know it's interesting to me that we
have the first layer
zero and the last layer is zero which is
what you would expect but then there're
just the wrong number of things within a
specific layer can I do anything with
that can that tell me
anything I don't think that tells me
anything
that doesn't even make sense because
they can't
have they can't have that number of
first channel is always zero so they
yeah
somehow four agents 20
[Music]
trash one bin should be
25 25 at
most
you might have to look at this Xander
I'm having uh I don't know
here I thought this like this looks
correct and all the like the prints look
correct as well and then it gets into
python wrong um
like it's like the wrong number of ones
though it's not just the wrong shape
we literally check the OBS as they're
coming
this was the more the most productive
part I had right here was these
this this debugging right here
okay so this is literally printing
out these bites like one by one
so Agent
Zero we
get one two 3 four five and then the
original agent one there's the
two one
oh wait now this doesn't
match doesn't match for agent two oh
because I'm still printing agent
Agent Zero agent one has this two
here and then here's your
two your
3 it's all correct
I'm going to have to keep debugging this
later because I can't figure out what
the hell's wrong with this
um that drives me absolutely
insane like I can see
the data looks good in
C and then somehow it's wrong in
Python I know that you passed the
correct and num
agents increment here
mobs what if I leave this what if I
leave these prints in
so
here we have agent
three you can
see Up's coming out
here
two one two
oh
why hang
no why is there this ghost
one hang on
maybe it is wrong in
uh
one now this is
fine wait is
wrong so these prints are
weird oh no this is yeah this is this
one is definitely
wrong so there is an indexing
bug how's that happen cuz it's like most
ly
right is Agent one fully
not why wasn't I catching that in the
pure sea
C but then when you run it through
python it's wrong
me damn it Xander this one's on
you let me see if this fixes it I think
this one's on you
that's freaking
evil let me make sure
we need better
um we need better compile flags for our
python versions to prevent that from
happening that would get caught by
compile Flags
first I'm pretty confident now
though I found
yep
okay so Xander the reason I've been
debugging this for the past
hour what is wrong with this right here
you tell me e
yeah I'll give you the hint it works in
C it it doesn't work in
Python your M now literally trains in 20
seconds by the
way all right you give
up ready here's the change
I was using that in compute
observations and it was not initialized
for python it was only in the C
version so now I can do M total num
OBS where is it oh right
okay so I
can uh what is it demo
and okay I can
build and now it'll
work it was writing garbage everywhere
because total noobs was not initialized
so it was zeroing a random amount of
memory this now works with zero % M time
there you go let that be a
lesson be careful what stuff you put in
a knit versus allocate allocate is just
the extra stuff that is only needed in
C really that shouldn't have very much
in it at
all there you
go uh I'm going to get rid of the
prints and then I'm going to push
this and I will allow you to uh to train
a new
policy and do some stuff
there yep that's why I've been stuck for
the last hour indexing was
correct that thing was off
hi this soft topic but how do I
contribute to puffer lib I've made an M
nowhere near as complicated current
ocean Ms also know where is fast get
around 300K SPS uh you just jump in the
Discord discord.gg puffer show us what
you've built um link us code and I will
do a live review of basically anything
that you are willing to contribute we do
try to get the ocean M that we take a
fair bit faster than that um but I will
check the uh I'll check the code and see
cuz usually usually I find new contribut
there's just a bunch of ways to make uh
M code way faster let me merge this real
quick I've been fighting this this bug
for the last hour finally got
it at least now I don't have to go to
bed after uh go to get dinner and go to
bed angry
yeah but Xander if you wanted to like
really improve this thing the other
thing you could do is you could just
make the OBS a straight up one hot um
you could just make the M's a straight
up one
hot and then you'd be good yeah post the
thing in the Discord I'm going to go
grab some dinner um for all the folks
watching this if you're looking to get
involved with this it's just puffer doai
we've got everything on the homepage
GitHub star it it really helps us if you
start the GitHub actually uh Discord
right here Discord GPU join this this is
where literally everything
happens there's like no you you don't
have to submit a resume you just you
show up and you start building stuff
it's that easy
um and then there's also my X where I
post a whole bunch of stuff on
reinforcement learning and the like so
if you're interested you can follow me
there as well and this gives you
notifications when I'm live I'm Live
Here YouTube twitch it's multi
streamed that's pretty much everything
um I am going to go get food I will
review B bets blast RM tomorrow I guess
I think he's PR PR it and I will see you
all around bye